a particular day for europe
because a new season is starting
you know that today at midnight the
united kingdom will officially leave and of
course after three years of work
we are also here to take stock of the
discussion we had with our
british friends we realized that
the  the european union
has obtained many advantages from this discussion because it has
confirmed itself as much more united we are
aware of a European space that is
precious for europeans but also for the
world it is a european market which is
naturally the first economic market on
the planet to face challenge d'  egypt
legend business in the uk jones member
states of these years has become a
unique nations office on it is not
because of shopping in god and therefore there is
a fundamental question of these three
years that i invite you too to
answer but why  everyone wants to
divide us why everyone is trying so
hard to divide the european space is
the question of questions in this
moment because even in our countries
some temperaments are
trying to support this initiative of forces of
powers that seek to make
the European Union more fragile but why
are we the most important economic area in
the world but we have a fixation
on it  our British friends have also taught us
and for this we
are grateful to them that we want this dimension
regulated because with
rules we live better and defend even the
weakest
and instead when there are no rules it is
only the strongest who prevail and  we
Europeans are made like this
but there is someone who would like to divide us
because perhaps they are afraid of a
regulated world ask this question true
given your answers of course
there isn't only one but I believe that at this
moment in this question and in the
answer that  we will be able to give
there is
the importance of
the european union while close to the european union and
as [ __ ] the european union of love not
only from d  join the files